the biggest leadership gap in our
generation
is the unwillingness
by the majority of people
to see the value of perpetually learning
please don't stay quiet because you know
it doesn't matter and you know it won't
play well in the room do not act like
you know
when you don't know
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the 10 small
habits that can have a huge impact on
your life enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one keep up with modern technology with
mark cuban i focus on things
that are
ai driven artificial intelligence driven
whether it's machine learning deep
learning learning neural networks um
medical applications but within ai ai is
a buzzword that everybody's using right
now you know every and and to that point
you know we as old guys we go back and
it's like 1995 we talk about the
internet and i would say to people back
in 1995
look if you don't understand the
internet you're not going to be able to
do business
and now that's just blocking the
tackling it seems obvious back then it
wasn't right i could even take you
further back to my first company you
know what we did it was a company called
micro solutions and we did local area
networks on wide area networks and i
used to walk into companies and and say
you're going to have to hook these pcs
together at some point that'll make you
more productive more effective you know
give you a competitive advantage and
people are like now i just carry this
floppy from this pc to that pc
yeah okay um
but
today we're at the same type of
inflection point with artificial
intelligence
you don't have to be an expert and be
able to put together your own neural
network you know you don't have to know
what weights and biases are
but
but
you have to have more than just a
cursory understanding
just like you have to know the
difference between
you know different types of websites and
you have to understand e-commerce if
you're in e-commerce you have to have a
cursory understanding of how apps work
you're going to have to have at least if
not more cursory understanding of
artificial intelligence because it will
change
everything we do and if the internet was
10x in terms of change to business
artificial intelligence will be 100x or
more there's going to be a disruption
and change in the types of jobs that's
going to impact your customers that's
going to impact your businesses that's
going to impact the future of business
and so
i can't i don't want to be
you know
i want to be as clear and as forceful as
i possibly can because as fellow
entrepreneurs
we always have to look for an edge we
always have to understand how our
industry is changing we always have to
understand not only
how we differentiate ourselves in our
companies but you always i always want
to know who can kick my ass right and
all my business is
who can kick my ass and can i kick my
own ass first
because if you can disrupt yourself
first
you're the person who could otherwise do
it
is not going to do it and you can
compete and be successful
so pay attention to ai it's important i
mean look if you go to my house right
next to my bed there's a book
machine learning for dummies
if you go into my bathroom there's deep
neural networks for dummies right if you
go on
there's a something for dummies in every
room of my house you know
[Music]
they can go two ways i know but i'm just
telling you
put the time i mean i've taken you know
i can't even tell you how many hours now
i spend every week if not daily working
like i'll go into amazon aws and go
through their machine learning tutorials
don't think to yourself i'm not
technical enough or i'm not going to get
this or i don't get into this or it's
too much try it get as far as you can
because it's like doing a basic website
and a little bit of html
just having done that you feel smarter
and you feel a little bit more confident
about this
you know i don't want to be an alarmist
but i'm trying to scare the hell out of
you because it's important habit number
two always keep learning with les brown
the biggest leadership gap in our
generation
is the unwillingness
by the majority of people to see the
value of perpetually
learning
that
we have to be willing to commit
ourselves to what alvin koffler talked
about to unlearn
learn learn relearn
because
today
innovation
creates new ignorance
and new ignorance can only be eliminated
by
education knowledge is the new currency
and so as we look at ourselves look at
our goals and dreams we must
continuously upgrade our knowledge
so that we can stay ahead of artificial
intelligence habit number three air your
views with gary vaynerchuk here's a
really really important piece of advice
that i think will bring you value
please
don't stay quiet because you know it
doesn't matter and you know it won't
play well in the room now that doesn't
mean be like me and be super combative
it means be respectful but let me give
you one humongous piece of advice
the world's gonna change animatics are
the stupidest [ __ ] of all time
ipsos is the stupidest [ __ ] of all time
it can't sustain itself and it will
break and it's getting closer than you
think so
it's important for you to share your
actual points of view in these rooms
because people are watching
and right now you may be frowned upon or
it's silly or it's naivete or it's a kid
talking but everybody's watching and
listening and in three years when that
person's fired and it goes to a new
place and they have to win in digital
they're gonna be like hey she knew and
so die on your sword
a lot of you are staying quiet because
you know will help you grow but you're
not you're not a you guys are agreeing
to things you don't actually believe in
you're doing it because within the four
walls you work in that's what you know
the rules are
it seems like it makes sense the problem
is we're at a point of transition and
what always happens at a point of
transition is people you guys are in a
very precurious spot you're the last of
the mohicans
so
you're you're going to uphold the past
because it's going to play in the room
but you're also going to live through a
career where it's going to be frowned
upon when you when you know
when you apply to the progressive places
they're going to want to know where you
sit on this what did you do about it
we're gonna talk to the clients or the
other people like if you don't have a
track record of at least communicating
your points of view you're definitely
not gonna have work habit number four
have a service mindset with jay shetty
let's take that salesperson
the more time that person spends
in empathy
their customers pain
and what the customer is really looking
for
the better they're going to be received
yes
so that service mindset always helps
because if you're thinking about and
this is what it comes and i said this to
my team when we were writing the book
and everything i was working on i said
if i sit here right now
and all i'm thinking about while i'm
writing the book is being a best-selling
book then guess what i'm now not writing
the book i'm now living in the future
and i'm not living in the present and so
the only way to make this a best-selling
book is to do the process properly and i
don't think and this is what i do and
this is the only thing that's helping me
and again i go through all the time
after my first video went viral three
four years ago
i stopped creating because of the
pressure that i wouldn't be able to live
up to it
so i actually got scared because i was
like oh well what if the next video
doesn't do as well everyone's going to
think i'm tanking like you get into that
self-doubt and that self and i got into
that space where i was just thank you
for being honest about it yeah no really
like genuinely i didn't want to make a
video again because i was like this
video just got 40 million views like how
am i ever going to beat that right and
you get scared i'm not putting anything
out i'm just going to stop and then i
started to realize i was like well now
i'm not living in service anymore
i'm living out of ego and i'm living for
feeling a certain way and guess what i'm
not feeling better by not putting
anything out yeah and actually if i just
serve more i'll learn more so the way
i've made sense of it and there's a
verse in the gita that explains it too
is that you have full control
over the preparation
the process and the practice
but you have no control over the
potential result but all of those three
things are the result in and of
themselves yes and so if you get
addicted to the process of writing the
practice of connecting with the right
people who can help share your work
and hey like you said i am focused on
the process of making sure that the most
people in the world have the opportunity
to buy this book
but then if they choose not to buy it i
can't control that but i can control
making sure that it's in front of
everyone and that i believe in the
context and that to me is not attachment
that to me is not uh ego that to me is
trying to live your best life i mean
like you know if you didn't just try if
you're like i wrote this book but who
cares yes i mean that's not service
either because the way i explain it and
i'm not i'm not claiming that this is it
and i'm not trying to say i'm it i'm
trying to say that
i think we all feel this way if
you or me see an amazing movie we want
to tell everyone about it
if you read an amazing book you want to
tell everyone about it if you found the
cure to cancer you tell everyone about
it for me i got to live an incredible
life thanks to these amazing teachers i
met
i just want to tell everyone about it
like that's all i'm doing yes but i want
to tell everyone because of how powerful
it was
everyone i have been reading a bit from
my friend's book evan carmichael built
to serve and i wanted to share this with
you so
according to a study by carnegie mellon
university people with supportive
spouses are more likely to give
themselves the chance to succeed they
studied 163 married couples and found
that people with supportive spouses were
more likely to take on potentially
rewarding challenges those who accepted
challenges experienced more personal
growth happiness and psychological
well-being now i can truly say that i've
experienced that in my life when i first
met my wife i was just starting out i
had never released a video i hadn't
created any content and she was such an
important part of feeling supported on
that journey so whether you're in a
relationship whether you're dating
whether you're married or even if you're
single being supported by friends and a
strong community is important uh build
to serve by ellen carmichael great book
on how you can find your purpose and
also on reminding us that we can all
make a difference in the world thanks
evan habit number five take a step back
and detach with jocko willink we were
doing a training operation we get into
this tactical situation
everyone in my platoon is focused on one
area everyone's looking down their
weapons waiting for a threat to expose
itself which means you got 16 guys
looking down their weapons and i'm
waiting for someone to make a call i was
a new guy i'm waiting for someone above
me in the chain of command to say hey
move here or hey move forward or make
some kind of a decision
and as i'm waiting no one's doing it so
so i'm a new guy
i'm scared to say anything and i know i
shouldn't say anything so i'm just
waiting
and no one's giving an order no one's
giving any direction
so i wait longer and this goes on for
probably
30 seconds or a minute which is a really
long time when you're trying to take
down a target
and finally i said to myself all right
i'm gonna see what's going on so i
actually point my weapon at the ceiling
and i take a step back and i just look
around and and i see that every single
person in my platoon
including my platoon commander including
the assistant platoon commander
including the platoon leading petty
officer everyone is just focused on
their weapons and no one's making a
decision and i can see this and because
i'm looking around and i'm detached from
the scenario just by just by eight
inches i stepped back stepped back to
look around
i can see what decision needs to be made
and so i i summoned up as much courage
as i could as a new guy because new guys
don't make decisions and i said
hold left clear right which is a basic
command that we had rehearsed and you
would practice and i expected someone to
say you know shut up shut up jocko
but instead they repeated the command
they all said hold left clear right
which means we were going to execute it
and sure enough the guys in the left
held and the guys on the right cleared
and we got done and instead of someone
saying hey you need to keep your mouth
shut like one of the more senior guys
said hey good job up there way to make a
call
so i looked at it i said wait a second
how could i have an as a new guy have
made a decision in that situation
that was better than what the more
senior more experienced guys were making
and i realized it was because i took a
step back and detached from it so at
that moment i said to myself okay from
now on when i get into these tactical
scenarios i'm gonna take a step back and
i'm gonna try and look around and i'm
gonna try and detach myself from the
chaos and the mayhem
and i started doing it all the time in
every tactical situation in the land
warfare in the mountains in the urban
environments i was doing it all the time
and i was able to like see what was
happening it was like a superpower to be
able to see what was happening
and make decisions and so then i
actually started doing it when i was
having conversations and if you and i
were in disagreement
and you started getting emotional
instead of me getting emotional back at
you i would just take a step back and be
like oh okay he's really he's really
concerned about this why is he so
concerned what does he see that i don't
see and i started actually just
detaching all the time and that became
a very powerful tool in leadership that
i used to this day how about number six
own your worth with marie forleo i think
all of us um when we love what we do and
when we're passionate about something we
almost have this sense of guilt about
being paid for it we shouldn't be paid
for it we can't ask for money oh i'll
just do it this one time oh i can't
charge that much i'm taking advantage of
someone else and so there's a lot of
sometimes subconscious sometimes just
deeply lodged beliefs about our own
worth and money and being paid for
something that we're really good at
that is important that we investigate
that we challenge and that we choose our
own beliefs around money as money is
this incredible thing and a lot of women
a lot of people in general but
especially women there's a lot of
conflict part of us wants more and part
of us feels guilty or greedy for wanting
it and like we're bad or somehow that
makes us i don't know less spiritual
less soulful less authentic and i think
that's total bs i think money is amazing
it is the most incredible tool that you
can use
not only to take care of yourself and
your family but more importantly that
you can funnel to
ideas and causes and real problems in
this world that take resources to help
fix
and
that's really exciting to me and i think
that
the more that women are financially
empowered the more everyone wins i mean
the studies have proven this time and
time again that when women
get financially empowered they take
better care of their families better
care of their kids they actually tend to
have less kids especially in the
developing world communities become
stronger
nations become stronger and really the
whole global economy is going to come
stronger so i get really fired up about
women owning what they're worth getting
very comfortable with money getting very
comfortable asking for it and also
becoming stewards of it meaning how are
they spending it on a day-to-day basis
are they feeling like you know what i
have enough right now to give to causes
i believe in i have enough right now to
invest in my own education my own
business my own future i think those are
really important issues and i think as
women we can't shy away from money we've
got to really dive into it and be
willing to swim around and investigate
all the places that we have screwed up
beliefs and that's okay all of us have
screwed up beliefs about something but
with money it's like we've got to get
this straight it's vital happen number
seven ask for help with ian lavenzent do
not act like you know
when you don't know
and do not act like you don't know when
you do know
some of y'all know you out of order as
hell
and you acting like
moi
some of you know you don't need to be
out there buying another piece of fried
nothing in that marketplace
[Music]
you know right now your sugar high as
hell
[Applause]
sneaking around the little pole trying
to eat up that little piece of uh
praline put that thing down
don't act like you don't know when you
know
and don't act like you do know when you
don't know
you know one of the beauties of me and
fix my life is people have become
willing to ask for help
we don't know
so many of us just don't know
we don't know how to do this
we don't know how to be successful when
they called me and told me that they
wanted my product on hsn they told me i
needed a dun and brad street number
i almost peed on myself
what the hell
the gun and hootie why
that's something that white people do i
don't know nothing about that
i read about that in the one wall street
journal that i read 15 years ago
but when
you are growing
and living
beyond the places that are familiar you
got to be willing to do stuff that
scares you
and that's when you're going to have to
rely on your connection to something
bigger greater and grander than you
ask for help
do not be so willing to buy real estate
in what is comfortable and familiar in
your own mind
as much as i'd done and grown and healed
there's still things that i need to
learn
and if i need to learn it
we all need to learn it because we're
all just one
don't act like you know when you don't
know
ask for the help that you need
and don't act like
you
do know that you don't know when you do
know
because you're convincing yourself that
you can't be trusted
trust what you know
you knew
when you met boo
you know he was crazy as hell
[Applause]
[Music]
you saw the crazy right round the edge
and you said but he cute
[Applause]
don't excuse crazy
you just shoot across the street i told
you that 23 years ago when you see crazy
coming across the street habit number
eight listen to your intuition with
lewis howes i was 25 324 i read the
alchemist
my favorite and like the end of the book
is like the treasures within you don't
go look around the world trying to find
the treasure i think that was pretty
much the ending so sorry to give it away
if you haven't read it but the treasure
was within me i was like oh wow i have
all the answers i need within me
and then i started like
asking myself the questions now i'm a
professional question asker to everyone
else also now
but i've always been asking myself the
questions
and
i've found that my intuition has never
been wrong
and i go i've gone against my intuition
a lot specifically in relationships
like i'll get into relationships i'm
like this is not the right thing for me
but something is telling me like i want
to conquer this or i want to help this
person i want i'm desiring this and then
i stay in it way too long and my
intuition's like get out but my head is
like yeah but what about this and it's
fulfilling this need
and every time something doesn't work
out and i knew i knew it wasn't going to
work out my intuition was telling me
like why are you doing this
number nine don't run away with mel
robbins there's a lot of you
that are running from things
instead of running two things
and that's a huge difference running
from something
versus running to something and so i
want you to think about that for a
minute um
because you don't have to move across
country to change your life
and you don't have to do something
drastic to experience drastic positive
change
and here's the thing about running away
from your problems
running away from your past have you
ever noticed that when you run
away
it tends to follow you
you know i used to uh have this problem
in relationships
and the reason why i had this problem is
because i was a very unhappy person
i didn't like myself truly as a person
until probably four or five years ago i
spent as sad as this is i spent the
first 46 years of my life really not
liking myself really um feeling like i
wasn't a good person
really questioning the sanity of people
that were in love with me or that were
friends of mine because i had such a low
opinion of myself and it didn't matter
you know i i was guilty not of moving
from one city to another
but i was guilty of moving from one
person to another
that i would literally
get in a relationship i would be in a
relationship for a year and then i would
start to feel that unsettled feeling
because what happens after a year of
being in a relationship well you got to
start working on it it's no longer the
thrill and the delight and it's new and
you're dating now it's just you and the
person in your life
there's nothing new about it and so all
your old crap starts to show up and
that's when you got to start to do the
work and so it was about the year or the
year and a half mark in almost every
single relationship that i would start
getting that itchy feeling and the
reason why i was getting that itchy
feeling is because my past was now there
this new relationship was no longer new
and so i was no longer distracted by it
and i was going to have to
deal with myself in order to be happy
and so what did i do for years not even
just years decades everybody i'm not i'm
not proud to admit this but i would
literally jump out of one relationship
and into another new one because another
new one would distract me from the fact
that i was an unhappy person
true story and i think a lot of you who
are unhappy with yourselves are looking
to move jobs or looking to move uh the
city that you live in or you're looking
to change your relationship and the
problem isn't where you live the problem
isn't your job the problem isn't the
person that you're with the problem is
how you feel about yourself and habit
number 10 the last one before a very
special bonus clip is be happy with
oprah winfrey i'm content i'm not just
relaxed i'm content because i know a lot
of rich people who are not happy
but i am not one of them
but when you're i am one of the happiest
rich people you are ever going to see
and you're trying to just when you're
trying to get away from it all and just
get away from everything you just relax
at one of your homes or yes i realize
well and also it doesn't take a lot for
me to relax i can uh i can be happy
looking at a leaf gail is saying what
are you sitting out under the trees with
your thoughts and i'll say yeah i'm
really i could be happy with the book i
can be happy reading poetry i can be
happy in front of a fire i can be happy
with my dogs i can be yeah
thank you now i've got a special bonus
clip that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action for
the next week when you watch a video and
just get motivated you have a 35 chance
of actually following through that's
what the science says and that is not
good enough believe nation we need to do
better when you actually get motivated
and then create a specific plan of
action for what you're going to do this
week you have a 91 chance of following
through and when you publicly commit to
somebody else like leaving a comment
below on this video it jumps even higher
so i want that for you i want to know
your single biggest takeaway from this
video and your plan of action for the
next week so i can celebrate with you
you have michael jordan level genius at
something you
you you are the greatest the greatest in
the world
at something
and it's probably not what your parents
did or what you went to school for
it's sitting here somewhere deep buried
and you don't believe that you can do it
but until you actually lean in
on what you have michael jordan ability
genius at until you actually start doing
it
you'll never live the life that you're
capable of you'll you'll constantly be
doing
what other people want you to do living
up to other people's expectations
meanwhile knowing that you're capable of
more i often get into fights uh maybe
not fights discussions
maybe arguments with people about when
they're making youtube videos for
example thought leaders i'm i'm deeply
passionate about helping more thought
leaders get onto youtube i want to see
your message out there because i believe
that your message can change the world i
think your message can impact people's
lives that people like you
who you used to be they need to hear
your message and you're you're too
scared to get it up there and one of the
biggest
complaints or one of the biggest
objections people have is well i don't
know how to edit i don't know how to
film
and what they end up doing is you spend
20 minutes
making a video recording it and then
five hours editing it
what you're doing there is training the
wrong skill
if you want to make a video like this
right
gonna sit in your car i'm still just
making this video off of my phone right
now i just have like can you see my
glasses maybe you can see look i've got
a there we go this is cool look i've
just got a little mini handheld
whatever tripod i guess
a selfie stick more like it and in my
phone that's how i'm filming this video
that's it sitting here in the car while
my wife is in costco shopping and
getting some awesome food for us
if you spend 20 minutes making a video
filming it recording it and then five
hours editing it
you're just training the wrong skill
you'll never get great at the thing that
you have michael jordan level ability at
now if you said your ambition is to be
the world's greatest editor that's
different congratulations you're doing
it you're doing it but if you want to be
a thought leader a speaker an expert you
want to you want to learn to make videos
and be the front facing person then
spending 20 minutes on something to
actually improve your skill that's
improving your skill making a video but
five hours editing it you're just
not wasting time but you're you're
stealing from your opportunity
you're stealing from your ability you're
stealing from your best self
okay well what do i do evan what how do
i how do i then
create i don't want to put up something
that's bad
the thing that gets you there
is actually getting great at your skill
the michael jordan level skill
i'd rather you spend five hours
making a video doing it again and again
and again and again and again and again
and again so that you don't need
editing
that you're so good at the thing that
you don't need editing
because that's a skill that will serve
you for life
because when you go on stage
you don't get to edit yourself
right there's no second takes when you
go on
tv and you're being interviewed when you
go on people's podcasts you're being
interviewed if you you're teaching
yourself that you're only good when
you're edited
and that's not your micro jordan level
ability the most powerful way
and the easiest way to change your
thermostat setting is by adding people
to your circle
very close proximity that live at a
higher temperature in that area than you
do for example in your faith let's just
say you're a 75 degree or in your faith
you've already seen this you can't
possibly begin to regularly associate
with good godly people who pray
regularly who try to live righteously
and they're 110 120 degrees of of faith
in their life and not have that
proximity heat you up now you won't get
to where they are you'll get to
somewhere between where you are at 75
degrees and they are at 110 over time
you become 100 degree and you alter the
thermostat setting through association
same in business if you and i were to
hang around each other every single day
and let's say you were a 75 degree or in
business hypothetically and i don't know
that about you but let's just say you
were
and i was 150 degree and we hung around
each other all the time don't you think
through that association especially if
you had two or three or four people like
me in your life that just over time you
don't even feel it you're at 80 you're
85 you're at 90 you're at 95
and that's where you are we understand
the power of this with our children
because we know at school the teachers
have influence over them they're mentors
but the people that really have
influence over our children are they're
friends because they're around them all
the time and so we know it sets their
temperature this is true in fitness if
you're a 75 degree of fitness at every
meal every day at the gym all your
associations hypothetically speaking
we're with someone who was shredded and
fit the way you wanted to look at 150
degrees you know over time you get
heated up and so you can't be with
someone every day you can't be with them
all the time but the key is to get more
proximity in the areas that matter with
people whose thermostat setting is
higher than yours i am a product you are
listening to me right now because i've
been so obsessed with this concept of
adding new associations to my life that
live in the areas that i want to improve
in at higher temperatures than me it's
my obsession to this day i'll give you a
secret one of the reasons i even do my
show is i know that i'm influencing many
of these guests in the areas that matter
most to them through our proximity and
in some cases they do it for me and so
i'm obsessed with the power of
association but i don't just associate
see all personal says yeah you're the
five people you hang around
kinda
you really are the five to ten people
you hang around if you're conscious all
the time
of studying them of observing them of
asking questions of the fact that you
should be altering your thermostat
setting that's when it really moves it's
not just hanging around it's consciously
and intentionally spending time with
people
where you allow it to impact you where
you study them where you really observe
them where you're open to their
influence there has to be a level of
trust before you can do that where you
surrender yourself to them but it's not
just being around them it's
intentionally being around people that
alters that thermostat setting so power
of association is the main way to do it
kind of take us behind uh kind of the
current with michael was there ever a
moment that you guys spoke that you felt
like it energized you and you learned
from him yeah it was well it was crazy
man because my favorite player was magic
growing up and then i quickly realized
my father stole all my height and i was
gonna be a six nine point guard so i had
to you know so look at this young guy
coming up and the thing that i marveled
at wasn't the fact that he was getting
to the rim and doing these fancy stuff
it was like how is he getting to the rim
how is he doing it
right you look at the footwork you look
at the fundamentals look at the spacing
the pacing
right and all those little things the
angles
and that's what becomes fascinating it's
like okay how do i get there right so i
started studying all those basics and
then when i came to the league the first
time i played against him um i want his
respect because it was like this kid's
not scared of me at all
right and he saw kendrick's spirit from
that standpoint and that started a
relationship
and it became something where it was
like
you know
text them anytime hits me right back
questions hits me right back and we're
talking all the time over my career
and
i've been in business over 20 years now
[Music]
people from all around the world
students at every level
whether they are
newly into launching their business or
they've been in business themselves for
10 15 years
ask the question how do i overcome fear
i'm about to disrupt you
completely because i am not
going to give you a strategy to overcome
fear because if i even attempt to give
you a strat and i know we're always
looking at stuff reading things how to
overcome fears they're probably 10 steps
to overcoming fear somewhere out there
they weren't written by me
and i could never write it
because i don't think
you wait to overcome fear
to live the life of your dreams or the
one that you deserve or to blow your own
mind
i personally and i'm teaching you from
my
life lessons from what i've studied what
i've applied what i've implemented what
i've fallen from what i've soared from
what i've gotten up from
and
i don't think you focus on learning how
to overcome fear though there are things
that helps to mitigate your fear
information mitigates fear
training and developing your skill set
mitigates fear i teach speaking i love
teaching people how to speak powerfully
not to speak to be great but to speak to
be unforgettable whether you're a
speaker or whether you're a manager
whether you're in retails or in network
marketing whatever it is when you open
your mouth you want to be unforgettable
and people always say lisa how do i
overcome the fear of speaking i say
let's not focus
on the fear of speaking because energy
grows where energy goes so let's not
focus on overcoming fear
let's focus on building a muscle
that naturally dissolves fear
and that muscle is the muscle of
information the muscle of education and
the muscle of skill set so if you know
more
and then you develop the skill set you
won't be as afraid to do that thing that
you're talking about but the other side
to that now i'm going to disrupt you a
bit so the first part not so disruptive
that means go getting more information
give fear what fear needs to to to
reduce itself meaning information skill
set but this other part that i'm gonna
tell you this might be disruptive
how about
you not try
to mitigate resolve or get past or
overcome whatever you want to call how
about you not try to do that with fear
how about you allow to fear to sit with
you you just commit to keep moving
even with the fear
so many times in my life and in my
career i was afraid
the difference between me and most is
that i still move forward with the fear
fear does not have a past to stop you
fear does not have a past to stop you
first of all let me just tell you this
just like compassion just like love just
like respect just like any other feeling
you feel for someone fear is just a
feeling we just give fear more power we
say when compassion comes i hug i love
when understanding comes when joy comes
when humor comes i laugh
but when fear comes i get to stop what
if you change the meaning to that oh
just just stick with me right here
what if
you change your dance with fear
what if you tell fear you're welcome in
my life because you're gonna come
and keep your way
but when you come
i'm not going to stop i quoted andrew
carnegie a few minutes ago
he said any idea that's held in the mind
that's emphasized that's either feared
or revered
begins at once to clothe itself in the
most convenient and appropriate form
available
depression
comes it starts out from ignorance doubt
and worry
i've got a chart i show it
doubt and worry
is on the negative side of life
understanding is on the positive side
don't worry comes from ignorance
understanding comes from knowledge but
you've got to study to get it
don't in worry are a psychic disease
it's an intellectual exercise
they're using their intellectual factors
to build a negative idea
and that's all they see
they take and internalize that and they
get emotionally involved with it it goes
from don't worry to fear
they've emotionalized the doubt or worry
turns into fear
the fear is in the emotional mind and
the emotion must be expressed through
the only instrument that can be
expressed through the physical body
so it moves a body into a state we call
anxiety
anxiety is never expressed anxiety
suppressed
the suppression turns to depression
they've all led up inside they
suppressed the fear
it turns into depression the depression
turns into disease
the disease turns into decay saint
claire lewis was right he said we don't
die we kill ourselves now what is the
opposite of all that you go from
ignorance to don't worry to fear
anxiety suppression depression disease
disintegration go over on the other side
you go from understanding
to emotional state called faith
you just know it's going to move into
form because you understand the law
faith doesn't believe in something you
can't see
strange thing about faith and fear they
both demand you believe something you
can't see
why would people choose fear over faith
because they're ignorant
so you go from understanding to faith
the faith manifests on the physical
plane not as anxiety as well-being
the well-being is not suppressed it's
expressed
and the expression turns to acceleration
you're building energy
and that is because there's no disease
you're at ease
and that turns into creation not
disintegration
it's all it's all a mental trip that
they're building outgoing now they go to
the doctor the doctor gives them valium
or some kind of drug to cool them out
he gets them numb so they don't know
what the hell they're doing when you
really look at the credit it is
improved nutrition and sanitation
so people were dying of malnutrition
which made them more susceptible to
infections and other disorders
and then sanitation and vaccination
that's how we it's not antibiotics let's
say it's not pharmaceuticals it's still
conditions of living you know better
hygiene better nutrition
but now
the increment to that
is understanding what causes accelerated
aging lack of sleep
stress
unhealthy emotions like hostility and
anger
and resentments and guilt and shame and
depression and anxiety lack of mind-body
coordination that's where the yoga and
the breathing techniques come in
poor nutrition right now most of our
food
that comes
to us
at home
is manufactured refined processed
contains chemicals contains antibiotics
contains steroids because animals are
fed that and even you know there are
pesticides in the ground which are
petroleum products how does that cause
accelerated aging it causes inflammation
of something called the microbiome which
is
the genes that are in your gut which are
microbial genes
so 99
of the genetic information in your body
right now
is not human you only have one percent
of the genes in your body are from your
parents
99 of the genes in your body right now
are microbial you're a few humans i'm a
mutant i'm like an x-man
you're a few human cells hanging on to a
bacterial colony so when you put food in
your mouth the first thing that they
encounter the food encounters is these
bacterial genes and if your food is
inflamed then the bacterial genes get
inflamed causes inflammation in the body
you get metabolites
that are called cytokines there's lots
of complexity between the human genome
the microbiome and lifestyle but knowing
this we can extend on it when people
really get a chance to think and have
the space that they can
quite easily discern between the things
that are essential to them important to
them and those things that are not
the problem is not our ability to
discern it's that we don't have the
space
to take the time to discern once we have
that perspective we can think through it
so my position is that we need to
develop a routine
that enables that space to think in a
world where we have so much information
we need more time
to think and process it not less
and so
you know one ceo that i interviewed for
the book has two hours on his calendar
every day
broken up into half hour segments so
that he has this space to stop to turn
everything off to think to see the
bigger picture i think we could all do
something similar to that of course you
struggle to remember it in your
day-to-day life because life is
difficult and it's harder to do things
than not to do them and it's harder to
do them well than to do them badly you
know and it's easy to sit around and be
hopeless i don't mean it's emotionally
easy because it's not but it's
procedurally easy to be useless and to
fall back into your old habits and to
not discipline yourself and
it's a matter of continual practice slow
continual practice and i think a good
example of that is something like weight
lifting you know if you start a weight
lifting program which i would recommend
by the way because it it's tremendously
advantageous physically and cognitively
you're not going to really see results
for a number of weeks and then the
results are rather slow but you can get
pretty decent results over a six-month
period and absolutely stellar results
over a couple of years and so you have
to make sure your time frame is right
and not to be too hard on yourself and
i did mention the future authoring
program
earlier and
one of the things i would recommend too
is if you're having a hard time
implementing your
your decisions say your ethical
decisions that you spend a bit more time
thinking them through and writing them
down and the future authoring program is
really helpful for that that's why we
designed it
and so
get your goals straight and continue to
practice every day and if you're not
succeeding then make your goals slightly
smaller you want to you want to make
your goals large enough so that they
challenge you but small enough so that
you have a reasonable probability of
succeeding at them on a day-to-day basis
and then you have to also understand
that if you fail on a given day like
let's say you're trying to quit smoking
and you quit for two weeks and then you
have a cigarette and you think oh my god
now i've screwed it up i've i'm not
quitting anymore you smoke a whole pack
of cigarettes it's like well
there's a couple of mistakes there and
one is
well just because you had a cigarette
doesn't mean you failed it just means
that you had a cigarette you can start
stopping again the next day
and the fact that you had one cigarette
in the last two weeks is a hell of a lot
better than the two weeks that you had
before that
and so you've got to be
realistically humble you've got to be
ambitious enough in your goals so that
you're pursuing something that you
regard as truly meaningful and
worthwhile
you know and maybe you can judge that to
some degree if you think about someone
you love attempting the same thing and
think about how you would feel if they
managed it and if you would feel good
then that's probably a good
what would you say that would be a good
evaluation strategy to use on yourself
the meaning behind stay hungry
[Music]
it's a form of consistency
motivation
and never lack hunger
i've been hungry
and i stay hungry in the sense that even
when you don't have nothing
you don't settle for less
as always say when you're on ground zero
the only way to look is up
so you keep on achieving you keep on
achieving
and i've been fortunate enough
to be
around some
successful people in mind
and
they never lack a sense of ambition and
hunger
so to stay hungry just about maintenance
consistency
never losing the hunger
the king of the jungle
you know making sure that your dominance
is known
and people approach you with caution
because they know when they're dealing
with you they're dealing with someone
who's ambitious
determined
you know they have commitment to their
cause and that's what stay hungry
represents the problem is shutting down
emotionally
is you stop learning
emotional learning stops when you shut
down
so you shut down to protect yourself
but for development you need
vulnerability vulnerability from the
latin word vulnerary vulnerary the wound
so vulnerability is a capacity to be
wounded
and nothing grows when it's not
vulnerable
a tree doesn't grow where it's hard and
thick it goes where it's soft and green
and vulnerable a crustacean animal like
a crab cannot grow
encased in a hard shell to grow
it has to mold make itself soft and
vulnerable same with children
when children shut down emotionally
they have difficulty learning especially
from negative experience
so they keep repeating the same stuff
over and over again and despite the
negative consequences they learn nothing
from it
and then the adult gets exasperated
i've told him a thousand times not to do
it and you're still doing it
well the proper response is
if you've told him a thousand times
and he's still doing it who's got the
learning problem here
clearly what clearly what we have to do
clearly what we have to do is we have to
find out what's going on for that show
when you focus on where you want to go
you actually go towards it the more you
focus on where you want to be the more
your mind
like a heat seeking missile takes you to
where you
want to be
so if you want to be an olympic athlete
you'd have to take a lot of action you
have to practice a lot and train a lot
if you don't want to do something
physical
train your mind practice with your mind
use mood boards i've done quite a few
radio interviews about why mood boards
are so successful why people
who have everything tend to have mood
boards now the mood board i made years
ago i put it above my bed
which is an odd thing to do actually
because i face away from it so i don't
look at it every day anymore but a
little while ago i looked at it and i
realized that
every single thing i put on that mood
board had come true in fact when i
finished with all the um
things i was going to do as a writer i
put up some pictures one was hot air
ballooning and one was something else
and i realized that every single thing
i'd put up i think one was riding a
camel i'd actually done all of those so
i thought well i better make a new mood
board now with new things i wanted i
wrote down some of the countries i
wanted to go to
so if you put it above your bed do make
sure that you look at it better to put
it really on your fridge or in your
kitchen or in your office you can also
take a big photograph of it and make
that your screen saver
and the wallpaper on your phone because
then of course you will look at it every
day over and over again
but even though i made that mood board
and put it in a place where i didn't
look at it and actually looked away from
it guess what it still worked so imagine
how it will work if it's right in your
line of vision if it's on your computer
screen and i work with many many women
who are having huge problems conceiving
and i get them to make a baby board same
thing but it's a picture of a positive
pregnancy test colored into yes it's
lots of pictures of babies
i have them also put that on instagram
and on their computer screen so they see
it every day and the success rates with
using that baby board are
phenomenal
make your mood board i believe yeah that
what we're seeking can only be found
inside of us um this is the exact and
that's where it gets really appropriate
this is where so this is why i'm kind of
insistent on inward be you know because
as and i'm still learning emotionally
because i was so dissociated it's still
taking me a long time to
be in body to feel my feelings to
differentiate between what is this
feeling i don't even know what to call
it
what to do with it so you know in a lot
of ways i'm still you know finding how
to meet my needs i'm still finding how
to be you know the spiritual being and
just speak my truth regardless of you
know how people are hearing it or
reacting to it um so that's that's in my
opinion the life work is all of us are
on the journey to meet our own needs now
again this doesn't mean
at the exclusion of others
i believe that the pathway to be fully
authentically connected with others
because we are interpersonal beings
humans are wired to connect we need
other humans yeah however
so many of us are operating on patterns
where we're trying to get needs met
through other people that we have to
focus inward first we have to be able to
fulfill ourselves meet our own needs
authentically before i can then
authentically present them to another
person in a relationship how many people
do you know maybe even you
have a job that just kills you it's
draining your energy you hate going
there maybe even a company that you
started that you thought was going to be
exciting but just it's just robbing the
life out of you or even school maybe
you're in college or even high school
and and it just
every moment of it is frustrating and
here's what we do we think to ourselves
when i get out of this job and i start
my own company then i'm going to be
fired up then i'm going to be excited
then i'm gonna take my life to the next
level when i get out of school i'm gonna
do it when i when i throw this company
away and i start the new company and
guess what that's the worst thinking
that type of thinking will keep you
exactly where you are so let me just
give you an example
i don't know if you know this about me
but when i was in my teens and my 20s i
worked on cars every single day of my
life i had a collision repair shop i i
got wrecked cars and people brought them
in and i fixed them i sucked fumes every
day i had dirt under my nails every
night i was literally scraping under my
nails trying to get piles of dirt out i
changed motors i did i rebuilt
carburetors i mean the worst thing i
hated was painting the cars because i
got such a headache even though we had
good ventilation i'd get such a headache
from the fumes but that's what i did did
i love painting cars
no i absolutely despised it i hated
every bit of it but i was lucky enough
to realize
that how you do any job is how you do
every job
and what i had to do was find things
that were exciting in that job because i
knew it was the stepping stone so here's
what i believe
so many people hate what they do their
lack of energy when you don't like
something you're not enthusiastic you're
not excited you're not nice to people so
you're just thinking i'm gonna get in
this groove but then something's gonna
snap and then all of a sudden i'm gonna
be amazing i'm gonna be excited i'm
gonna i'm gonna find that new job that
new career no you have to start now so
what you have to do like i did with the
collision shop is you have to find a way
for that dull job that thing that robs
your energy now to be exciting yes you
do as hard as that sounds
do it to the best of your ability and
guess what opportunity comes along in
places you won't even realize uh that
there isn't even there's an opportunity
for you example so i'm in the car
business hating it but i found a way to
be enthusiastic because what i liked is
i like the fact that a car would come in
wrecked i could visualize it looking
perfect again and visualize how excited
the person would be to get their car
back to new so when i was working on
cars i didn't think i got
bondo on my fingertips paint on my nails
i got a headache from the fumes i'm
dirty it's sweaty if i thought about
that everything would have sucked but
what i thought about was how excited the
person's gonna be when they see their
car back to normal and i found a way to
be enthusiastic and excited if you asked
anybody like that guy loves collision
work
it's not true i wasn't lying i found a
way to manipulate myself so
in that instance my first big real
estate deal i did several with no money
down worked right my butt off to to get
it done but my first big real estate
deal that after years uh was the first
deal i did over a million dollars on
true story in my little town in upstate
new york a town called marlboro new york
and guess who i did the deal with
somebody who came into the collision
shop and i did work on their car lent me
the money because i was so enthusiastic
so excited such a good mood the guy's
like how do you have so much energy how
are you so excited i said well this is
just a stepping stone for me i'm working
on real estate deals i've done a few and
working on this bigger one he's like why
aren't you doing the big one i'm like
i'm trying to put the money together but
i'll get it i know i'll make it that guy
lent me eighty thousand dollars
just like that and he made a ton of
money for it i mean i i was so
appreciative of the loan he gave me i
did everything in my power to make sure
that deal crushed it people
misunderstand about success is
they're looking for the easiest way to
get that
you know and it's funny how many people
books have you read or
i won't say promote it but had on your
show and everybody goes
five easy steps
ten steps to greatness yeah you know
eight steps to this and
those steps for success they're infinite
they are
infinite you cannot
count them
it doesn't matter how long you've been
doing it those steps are constantly
shifting
you don't know if they're there
sometimes you have to trust that the
next step is going to be there when you
can't even see it and sometimes when you
step on that step you go right into
quicksand but you got to be able to
pull yourself back out of it again so
everybody's looking for these steps and
there are no steps so steps never never
end and you just can't climb steps
sometimes you got to crawl though those
steps and you finally get to the top
and everything shifts and you're at the
bottom and you get crazy
all right what does that mean sometimes
you're at the top and then you're at the
bottom again well you may get to the top
and you're like i'm here
and then you look back down and you look
up again you're actually on the first
step
you're on the first step again
and where you thought was the top is not
even the top it's the beginning wow it's
literally the beginning
of where you're supposed to be
and that's when most people just quit it
i just like it just drives me crazy
because everybody's like here
look at
i always people that i do the interview
with i always like to use them as an
example because people can relate to
that all right
you've been climbing steps for how long
to get to here to get
i mean since starting this it's been
over eight years but the journey before
then
it was you know decades to build myself
to prepare myself for this and now i
feel like i'm just getting started right
exactly so you have
it right exactly so all the steps that
you climbed just to get started yeah
just to get started and people don't
want to talk about those steps they
don't want to talk about those steps and
how difficult those steps are and how
many steps that you stumbled on and how
many steps you didn't even see and how
many steps that people placed in front
of you when they pulled and they pulled
them all pulled away people that you
were very close to people that you knew
that people that you thought that were
like hey these people actually have my
back except yeah they did have your back
but they were actually pushing you down
the steps
yes
no and
it's funny when you talk about those
things or people talk about them they
seem surprised but you should know that
in that path all those things are going
to be there identify my five major moves
if you read this book high performance
habits you know about the five major
moves so identify my five major moves
and i'm like i'll swiftly move towards
one because momentum can shift mindset
and so if i'm in a dark disappointment
down momentum like achieve some goals
but here's what's important notice i
said the five major moves
that's what i mean with progress because
what a lot of people mistakenly do is
they just start doing lots of tasks and
activities that aren't correlated in any
way to the meaningful pursuits of life
so here's what happened
i'm bummed i'm downed so i'm doing a
bunch of work
the next day they still feel bummed and
down because what was their work it was
a bunch of activities that actually
didn't matter they didn't give them any
meaning so if you're down
the most important working you'll be
doing is the ones that you do feel
connection enthusiasm meaning
fulfillment satisfaction from those ones
that do intrinsically bring you joy
those are the ones that i want you to
progress towards matter of fact i really
want you when you're feeling down
disappointed major setbacks dark days
what i really desperately want you to do
is stop multitasking and doing all the
little like busy work things that don't
matter
like
like put off like
if it's wednesday and
you know you got a stack of bills and
they're not due
for another
30 days
don't pay the bills that day because
that's not fun and you're you've got
plenty of time to do it later when you
fee like when you get over this piece
this funk like just say okay write the
date on those bills pay them on but
don't do it today because that's busy
work instead today
find an activity that you find to be
creative compelling engaging fulfilling
and do that progress towards the things
that have meaning that's huge when
you're down
but most people don't do that because
what's comforting just like eating
comfort food
is doing low hanging fruit activity
i'll pay the bills and answer a bunch of
emails you know but those small little
tasks
those don't give you enough bang for the
buck to really move through it and
there's a big misconception about that
in the culture including the science
that often says oh no no just you know
if people can complete small steps
small tasks
they'll feel better and it's like
well yeah i mean we all have this reward
system in our brain and a little
dopamine will fall out but do we do we
want a little
drip drip of dopamine or we want the
floodgates to come open and feel alive
so i want you to do the activities that
are more meaningful
not just like tasks
you know
it's really important i turned it around
you know i
i did my job
in four hours and i was on there there
was a wall that separated production
from the offices and the lunchrooms
because in production there was you know
quality control you couldn't go in there
unless you had hair nets and you know
protective equipment
so what i did is i borrowed some
protective equipment and i went in there
and i started hanging out with the
operators the people that were running
the lines and i started taking their
trash outside
and then
if they want this is cool this is the
truth i don't know you know people will
like it but if they wanted a cigarette
break
you know to go outside and smoke cause
you know this is 70 right you know
everybody smokes uh so i would say well
just show me what to do you know you
just be gone for five minutes and
they're like uh i don't know like oh
come on just i'm i'm a mechanic you know
i never really am
you know and uh so they would teach me
you know uh how to watch the line and
they would go outside
you know and i'd do that for a couple of
weeks and so so the other managers were
were telling my manager like hey uh
the guy on your crew that mops in the
night man hey uh i just want to thank
you for letting him take my trash out my
guys helped him and they were like what
who did that
you know and he was like
like okay he was like no one had ever
done that
you know you heard the whole statement
that's not my job
but after he told after he told me that
i i never said i said i'm employed here
that is my job
you know that is my job and
and little by little i learned how to
run the the dorito lines
you know how to and it is it is like
being a pilot it's not you know people
say you just make chips oh no no no man
it's like you got to go to pilot school
to learn how to make
doritos and potato chips and fritos
believe me it takes a couple years to be
a master you have a choice and and we it
doesn't seem like we have a choice
there are things that happen in life
that are not fair there are things that
happen that are in fact not right
um but but
where you choose to kind of look at that
from is ultimately how that thing will
play out in your life
and i chose to look at my mom as
somebody who didn't approve of me
and didn't think i was good enough
i didn't realize until much later that
well what if all of these criticisms
were to keep me on in line what if all
of these criticisms were designed
for me to turn out in a way that she
thought
i could
or or perhaps should to make it in this
life
and it was then that i started to get
that she raised me
with the tools that she had
and that i growing up i criticized those
myself i was criticizing her
but uh then i started to kind of get a
glimpse of
who she is as a human being theory of
narrative identity your narrative is
what you say about yourself it's how you
define yourself that's your identity
your identity is way more important than
your personality your personality is
surface level your personality is
external your identity is internal your
personality is the byproduct your
identity is the cause so however you see
and describe yourself whatever you
affirm of yourself and by the way
everything you say is an affirmation if
you say it's gonna be a bad day that's
an affirmation if you say it's gonna be
a great day that's an affirmation if you
say this video sucks that's an
affirmation if you say this video is
great that's an affirmation everything
you say is an affirmation of something
and everything you say about yourself is
also an affirmation of who you are and
here's what the research actually says
in psychology the research and this is
from daniel gilbert from harvard but
there's so many other researchers on
this
your future self is going to be a
different person than who you are today
you actually underestimate how different
you're gonna be in the future just like
probably your former self is more
different than you than you actually
give yourself credit for think about who
you really were 10 years ago think about
what mattered to you think about how you
spent your time think about what you
cared about chances are you've got
different values different priorities
different focus different goals and so
that actually brings up the point well
where does your identity come from your
identity actually comes from your goals
it comes from what you're trying to
accomplish it comes from what you value
and so what is it you're trying to
accomplish in your life right now is it
finishing that degree is it paying the
bills is it writing that book is it
becoming whatever it is you're seeking
whatever it is you're trying to do
whatever outcomes you're trying to
produce that's what's ultimately framing
your identity and your identity shapes
your behavior and your behavior over
time becomes your personality so here's
the quote
it's from albert einstein imagination is
more important than knowledge for
knowledge is limited whereas imagination
embraces the entire world stimulating
progress giving birth to evolution so
this is another thing that danielle
gilbert found in his research is that
most people they don't imagine a future
self in fact most people think that
their future self is basically the same
person they are today as daniel gilbert
said human beings are works in progress
that mistakenly think they're finished
so if you think that your future self is
the exact same person you are today then
you think you're a work in progress
that's
you actually don't think you're a work
in progress you think you're finished
and that's what carol dweck calls a
fixed mindset if you think that who you
are right now is who you're always going
to be then you don't have that much
imagination towards your future self if
you don't have that much imagination
towards your future self you're not
conceiving you know again back to the
napoleon hill quote whatever the mind
can conceive and believe the mind can
achieve if you view your future self as
a different person which by the way they
are your future self is going to be in a
different situation they're going to
have different goals different values
they're going to be in a different world
even think about how different the world
is right now versus where it was 5 10
years ago we are part of a culture and
our values in many ways are shaped by
that culture we're slow boiling into our
future selves just like the culture is
slow boiling into whatever it's slow
boiling into so you're slow boiling into
someone you're going to be different in
10 years from now the question is are
you going to live by design and
intention or are you just going to
fade based on whatever culture takes you
for me it comes down to
you know after you get beyond the rage
rage is is justified under oppression it
also can be really dangerous you got to
be careful not to be consumed by your
own rage
yeah you know and that's something that
i've worked really hard on and what i
loved about the peaceful protest it's
like peaceful protests put up a mirror
to the demonic imagery of your oppressor
and the more still you are in your
peaceful protest the more clear
the mirror is to
the oppressor
for the world to see and for them to see
themselves
you know so i was really encouraged by
how powerfully this generation was able
to hold that mirror so we all come to a
relationship with like expectations
about how we think people should act and
unfortunately we don't recognize our
expectations as expectations we
recognize them as truth this is how the
world is it is how the world should be
and when somebody we think that they
have those same beliefs and values and
rules and all that and so given this
scenario there's only one way to act
that is certainly obvious and so when
the person doesn't act like that we take
it personally like whoa do you not
respect me do you not love me do you not
care about me and it just isn't that
they have a different set of beliefs and
rules there's enough nuance difference
that they're not if they're intending to
hurt you you have a whole different set
of problems but assuming that they're
not intending to hurt you then you have
a communication problem so lisa and i
actually define our terms so we have a
few words in our
marriage that they mean something so if
i say hey baby it's important to me that
you leave that you know glass of water
on the table
then there she just wouldn't move it
period simple as like
the the word important like comes in all
caps with exclamation points glowing red
like that's like when we say it like
it's a drop whatever you're doing like
it's important that you do x y z now the
big thing is when you define a word like
that you can't ever abuse it so like i
would never say it's important to me
that you leave it you know it's got to
be it's just extraordinary like how many
times do i tell her something's
important in a year
i don't know six seven times in a year
so it's like it's really gotta be
limited and then another one is promise
if i say i promise i'm gonna do that
dude i'm going to
do
that like there's no two ways about it
so you never throw around promise ever
under any circumstances and so dude it's
like you really really have to be
hardcore and so and the other way that
we use promise is um if
if uh she says you know how does this
dress look on me i'm like yeah it looks
great and she's like you promise
then it's like all right all right it
makes you look fat what can i say i mean
it's like but then you you cut to like
the chase on something now the thing is
you can't say that all the time you
can't be like how's this dress make me
look fine promise uh what do you think
of this dinner you like it yeah i love
it promise like if you're doing that it
loses everything but if you're saving it
for like in fact god i almost don't
remember the last time i asked lisa to
promise something like that um but
you know that you haven't we certainly
use it more in the early days of our
marriage but even then like how many
times a year three or four i mean it's
like but it really forces you to respect
these things you make sacred in your
relationship
[Music]
if you want to learn the seven habits
that will make you one percent better
every single day check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there you start replacing and
filling that thinking loop with the
world has shifted i'm shifting too
pivoting is what makes people one of the
biggest differences that i made that
allowed me to create